Pero bien, acepté el desafío y decidí lanzar thedailydenouncer.com,
un sitio web que denuncia el terrorismo durante la semana,
porque nos tomamos los fines de semana.
Veamos un ejemplo,
que por lo general, aparecen como dibujos animados de un solo bocadillo:
"¡Denuncio el terrorismo! ¡También a los que nunca rellenan la bandeja de papel!"
La idea del sitio web es denunciar el terrorismo
y reconocer que es ridículo
tener que denunciarlo constantemente.
Pero si la intolerancia no es lo suyo,
la comedia de la justicia social es útil para todo tipo de problemas.
Por ejemplo, junto con mi compañero Lee Camp
fuimos a las Islas Caimán para investigar la banca offshore.
Estados Unidos pierde algo así como unos USD 300 000 millones al año
en estos paraísos fiscales en el extranjero.
No es por presumir, pero yo, al fin de mes
solo tengo de 5 a 15 USD de la renta disponible.
Así que entramos en estos bancos en las Islas Caimán
y preguntamos si podíamos abrir una cuenta bancaria
con 8 dólares y 27 centavos.
(Risas)
Los gerentes nos aguantaron 30 a 45 segundos antes de llamar a la seguridad.
Los chicos de la seguridad llegaron, presumieron de sus armas,
y nosotros acabamos chillando de miedo y huyendo
porque -- y esta es la última regla de la comedia la justicia social --
a veces estas cosas te dejan el cuerpo como un flan.
Se supone que la mayor parte de mi trabajo es divertida,
destinada a generar risa y un sentimiento de pertenencia.
Pero sí, a veces acabo de patas en la calle por los de seguridad.
A veces recibo tuits e e-mails llenos de odio y amenazas.
A veces correos de voz diciendo que si sigo contando mis chistes,
me matarán a mí y a mi familia.
Y esas amenazas de muerte no son divertidas en absoluto.
Pero a pesar de este peligro ocasional,
sigo pensando que la comedia para la justicia social
es una de nuestras mejores armas.
Es decir, hemos intentado diversas aproximaciones a la justicia social
como la guerra y los concursos de danza sobre hielo, sin éxito.
Pero aún así, muchas cosas siguen siendo horribles.
Así que creo que es hora de contar una broma muy buena sobre la caca.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)